بعيدا عن اوكرانيا يقع جزء كبير من شبكه
التجاريه العابره للقارات في شرق القاره
الصين تحديدا
وشركه بي اتش ار الصينيه مع حلو تركيز في
عضوا مؤسسا في مجلس اداره الشركه لاداره
صناديق الاستثمار في الاسهم هذه الشركه
ساهمت في ديسمبر 2021 بحسب نيويورك تايمز
في عمليه استحواذ شركه تشاينامو
الصينيه على واحد من اغنى مناجم القبل وهو
المعدن الرئيسي في تصنيعه بطاريات
السيارات الكهربائيه في الكونغو
الديمقراطيه وفي العالم
الاستحواذ تم من شركه
نحن في العام 2019 شركه
طاقه النوويه الصينيه اسمها سي جي ام باور
جروب في القائمه السوداء للتصدير الامريكي
وشركه بي اتش ار كانت المستثمر الرئيسي
عندك كتاب الشركه الصينيه في بورصه
استفادهنتر اربعه ملايين 8400 الف دولار
دفعتها الشركه لكيانه يسيطر عليها هنتر
وعمو جيمز سبايدر
تتحدث
2014 واشنطن وضعت شركه ابيك اوتو الصينيه
على القائمه السوداء للتصدير لكن رغم ذلك
تعاونن في 2015 بين بي اتش ار والشركه
الام الشركه الصينيه
للاستحواذي على شركته هناجس اوتو موتيف
الامريكيه لتصنيعه مكونات السيارات
وبموافقه من لجنه الاستثمار الاجنبي في
امريكا لكن اللجنه كانت تحت اداره
وزير الخارجيه وقتها جون كيري وزوج والده
شريكان في الشركه الصينيه
للصلابه وبالتالي فهو هدف سهل لتحقيقات
الجمهوريين لكن هل هذه التحقيقات قد طالوا
بايدا في الوقت الحالي
الحجه هنا انه كان على علم لكن على مدار
سنوات الرئيس الامريكي علمه بانشطه نجله
التجاريه ورغم ذلك فوكس نيوز اوردت دليلا
على علم باي باي التقى 14 من شركاء ابنه
تجاريين في الداخل وفي المكسيك في
اوكرانيا الصين وهكذا غسان اثناء توليه
منصب نائب الرئيس نحن في 2019 المكان
هكذاخستان نشر موقعنا مهتم بناء بمحاربه
الفساد صوره تجمع بيضا بكل من رئيس
الوزراء السابق كريم مازموف ورجل الاعمال
كنس الركيب
علاقته الاخير التجاريه بعنطر كانت محلات
تساؤلات
بين والده وبين راكشيف الذي كان يتطلع الى
استثمار جزء من ثروته في نيويورك و واشنطن
ونفادا وهذه المره العهده على بديل لكن
بعيدا واهنتر اتخذ قرار بعدم التحدث عن
هذه الامور ما اعرض كلاهما للهجوم حتى
داخل اداره الرئيس الاسبق اوباما كانت
غاضبه بحسب تحقيقا لنيويورك
اوباما ازدادت في ديسمبر 2015 مع اقتراب
المعركه الرئاسيه مع الجمهوريين لجلسه
مصحف ستايل المبعوث الخاص لاداره اوباما
لسياسه الطاقه
الخاصه بشركه الغاز الاوكرانيه بوريسيما
كانت صلبه
اتمنى ان تكون على درايه بكل ما تفعله
عبارات بيضا لنجله هنتر ابي حسب نيويوركير
فهل كان هنتر على درايه ام انه تورط وورط
والدهما